[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute
sonntag der dritte advent schön dass sie
dabei sind wie auch christian otto für
den sport mit einer premiere genannt und
das sind die themen vorleute
trümmer und fassungslosigkeit mehr als
30 tornados auf einmal schockieren die
usa ganze ortschaften sind ausgelöscht
und wahrscheinlich über 100 menschen tot
eine heikle reise in polen will kanzler
olaf scholz auch über die misstöne
zwischen warschau und der eu reden
und jetzt doch bereit zum impfen bayern
star joakim ich erklärt in einem
zdf-interview seinem sinneswandel aber
auch wo er sich unfair behandelt fühlt
wir beginnen mit dem schock in den usa
noch immer kann niemand genau sagen wie
viele menschen bei der tornado
katastrophe in der nacht auf samstag ihr
leben verloren haben mehr als 30
tornados wüteten in sechs bundesstaaten
besonders schwer betroffen ist kentucky
die stürme schlügen eine schneise von
über 300 kilometern länge benjamin
daniel und nina niebergall berichten
die menschen in mayfield kentucky
versuchen zu retten was nach den
verheerenden tornados zu retten und die
ganze stadt gleicht einem
kriegsschauplatz
auch roche matthias reifen laden des
komplett zerstört
ich bin nicht sehr traurig darüber ich
werde das hier wieder aufbauen ich bin
traurig weil andere ihre familien
verloren haben und ich bin einfach nur
froh dass es meiner familie gut geht
seine nachbarin trifft es viel härter
sie hat ihr kind verloren
in mayfield fürchten sie dass die
rettungskräfte unter den schuttbergen
noch mehr tote finden werden eine
tornado warnung für freitagabend gab es
zwar aber der sturm kam in der nacht
schnell überraschte viele im schlaf und
war außergewöhnlich stark
das heißt man konnte sich nirgends
verstecken der tornado war so groß so
kraftvoll dass man selbst in einem
unterschlupf und sein leben fürchten
musste viele gebäude in den usa sind nur
aus holz gebaut die zerstörung fällt
daher umso heftiger aus aber selbst eine
kerzenfabrik hielt nicht stand allein
hier sollen mindestens 70 menschen ums
leben gekommen sein
wir erleben große trauer in der stadt
natürlich insbesondere bei jenen die
angehörige verloren haben aber wir sehen
eben auch schon viele die bereits die
ärmel hochkrempeln mit dem wiederaufbau
beginnen und die ihren optimismus nicht
unter den trümmern suchen müssen
auch in diesen trümmern sind noch
verschüttete ein amazon verteilzentrum
in illinois den teilweisen einsturz des
dachs haben viele nicht überlebt
nach deutschland hier sind die korona
zahlen erneut gesunken allerdings fehlen
heute daten aus bremen und niedersachsen
das robert koch institut meldet 32
1646 neuinfektionen binnen eines tages
das sind 9409 weniger als vor einer
woche
132 menschen starben die inzidenz liegt
mit 300 90,9 erstmals seit fast drei
wochen wieder unter 400
nach neuen angriffen auf polizisten bei
corona protesten warnen poltiker vor
einer weiteren radikalisierung der szene
leider würden sich bürgerliche
demonstranten zu wenig von
rechtsextremisten abgrenzen sagte
bundesinnenministerium feser der funke
mediengruppe in 13 thüringen wurden
gestern abend nach polizeiangaben 14
beamte verletzt aus der menge von rund
1000 teilnehmern heraus versuchten
demonstranten die polizeikette zu
durchbrechen
in österreich ist der lockdown seit
heute in den meisten landesteilen vorbei
zumindest für geimpfte und genesene
ungeimpfte dürfen weiterhin nur nach
draußen um zu arbeiten oder einzukaufen
die sieben tage incidents fiel in den
drei wochen ausgangs beschränkungen von
1100 auf 380
schwieriger antrittbesuch für
bundeskanzler scholz er ist vor zwei
stunden bei den nachbarn in polen
angekommen
regierungschef moravetz begrüßte ihn mit
militärischen ehren heikle themen sind
sowohl die situation an der polnisch
russischen grenze als auch der streit
zwischen polen und der eu über fragen
der rechtsstaatlichkeit
fragen wir anne brühl in warschau wie
wird der neue bundeskanzler im tollen
empfang
na das ist schon ein besuch unter
besonderen vorzeichen die töne die da
aus der national konservativen
regierungslager in den letzten tagen und
wochen kommen die sind schärfer auch der
polnische ministerpräsident morawski hat
jetzt das thema reparationen
aufgegriffen eigentlich sollte in diesen
minuten eine pressekonferenz der beiden
beginnen das verzögert sich aber aber
dass der neue bundeskanzler nach polen
in seiner ersten woche kommt das zeigt
ja auch die bedeutung die er der
deutsch-polnischen freundschaft beim
lässt das ist allerdings auch eine
freundschaft mit differenzen vor allen
dingen beim thema justizreform hier in
polen da pocht deutschland auf die
einhaltung der rechtsstaatlichkeit auf
europäischer ebene und dieses betonen
einer europäischen stärke eines
gemeinsamen europas das ist etwas was
vielen hier bei vielen hier in polen auf
skepsis stößt das geht vielen zu weit zu
schnell
live aus war schon an der brücke vielen
dank
mit einer scharfen warnung an russland
ist das g7 außenministertreffen in
liverpool zu ende gegangen moskau müsse
im falle eines einmarschs in die ukraine
mit massiven konsequenzen rechnen
erklärte die gastgebende britische
außenministerium joss die ihren
zimmermann mit einer bilanz
verbundenheit durch handel das ist das
motto der britischen aussenministerin
und so hat liszt rus in die hafenstadt
liverpool geladen zwei tage lang beriet
sie dort mit ihren kollegen der g7 den
chefdiplomaten der bedeutenden
volkswirtschaften über die zahlreichen
krisen der welt die schärfsten warnungen
gingen in richtung kreml
wir haben ein kraftvolles signal an
unsere gegner und unsere verbündeten
gesendet wir waren sehr klar dass jedes
eindringen russland in die ukraine
massive konsequenzen nach sich ziehen
und einen hohen preis kosten wird weiße
werk aus auch für iran wählte trust
starke worte man werde dem land nicht
erlauben über atomwaffen zu verfügen
in der gemeinsamen abschluss resolution
erklärten sich die g7 besorgt über
chinas wirtschaftlicher zwangsmaßnahmen
am heutigen letzten tag waren auch
asiatisch pazifischen staaten zu gast
die deutsche außenministerin begrüßte
dass die g7 große infrastrukturprojekte
auch mit anderen regionen der welt
anstreben und zitierte das motto des fc
liverpool
sie und never walk alone ist auch die
leitlinie der zukünftigen deutschen g7
präsidentschaft dass wir diese gewählt
nur gemeinsam und nicht alleine
gestalten können damit ist der berg
nicht allein gestern abend wurden die
minister im beatles museum empfangen
spontan stimmte der japanische kollege
john lennons lied imagine am klavier an
einige kolleginnen sollen mitgesungen
haben
marietta slomka hat außenministerin
baerbock im interview um viertel vor
zehn im heute journal und im sport gibt
es gleich auch noch ein bemerkenswertes
interview aber jetzt erstmal den neuen
weltmeister in der formel 1 sehen und
was für ein unglaublich als erster
niederländer hat max verstappen den wm
titel in der königsklasse des
motorsports gewonnen im letzten rennen
mega clever gelöst im zweikampf mit
lewis hamilton kurz vorm ziel in abu
dhabi
minuten lang mit max deppen neben seinem
auto noch nicht begreifen was gerade
passiert ist durch eine safety car phase
fünf runden vor schluss und als folge
einer umstrittenen entscheidung der
rennleitung kann der niederländer in der
letzten runde den entscheidenden angriff
auf weltmeister lewis hamilton startet
hamilton kann nicht mehr kontern und so
gewinnt verstappen seinen ersten
wm-titel in der formel 1 mercedes legt
nach dem rennen protest ein eine
entscheidung steht noch aus stand jetzt
ist verstappen weltmeister nach der
spannendsten saison der formel 1
geschichte ein erfolg der seinem vater
jos verstappen niemals zuteil wurde
fußball-nationalspieler josua kimmig
lässt sich nun doch gegen korona impfen
seine meinungsänderung erklärt der
bayern profi in einem zdf
exklusiv-interview zu sehen unter
sportstudio de noch pausiert der
26-jährige
im nächsten jahr könnte mich bei den
bayern wieder voll mitspielen
flüssigkeit in der lunge verhindert
vorerst intensives training nach einer
corona infektion mit milden symptomen
im oktober war der nationalspieler in
die kritik geraten als er öffentlich
gemacht hatte aus persönlichen gründen
nicht geimpft zu sein davon rückt er
jetzt ab natürlich wäre es besser
gewesen mich früher impfen zu lassen
generell
war es für mich einfach
sehr schwierig mit meinen ängste und
bedenken umzugehen und deshalb war ich
auch so lange unentschlossenen deshalb
konnte ich diese entscheidungen zu dem
zeitpunkt auch nicht treffen kimmig
schimpft termin steht noch nicht fest
zunächst hat er den status eines
genesenen von folgeschäden für sich geht
der 26 jährige nicht aus
dreifach erfolg für die deutschen bob
fahrerin in winterberg laumann heute vor
marianna janka und kim ki bei den
männern dominiert weiterhin francesco
friedrich seit genau einem jahr ist der
rekord weltmeister ungeschlagen durch
seinen triumph im vierer verbucht er
seinen insgesamt 60 weltcupsieg und
kräuter führt bejubelt den ersten
bundesliga sieg der saison einzel 0
gegen union berlin so viel freude in
franken
das wetter steigert nicht wirklich die
stimmung als recht nicht die freude
morgen fällt in der osthälfte etwas
regen auch sonst ist es meist trüb erst
am nachmittag zeigt sich im südwesten
und westen kurz die sonne die temperatur
erreicht drei bis zwölf grad hier
übernimmt morgen jana pareigis wie ihr
sagen tschüss wünschen ihnen noch einen
interessanten dritten advent